Welcome to the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules as usual.
First, please mute um during the talk.
But if you have immediate questions,
you're welcome to unmute and ask or you
can use the chat room to post your
questions. There will be also an Q&A
session at the end. Second, today's
seminar is open to external audience, so
no classified discussion is allowed.
Finally, the talk will be record and
upload to our YouTube channel. Now let
me introduce our speaker. It is an honor
to host our own Dr. Yonu Choy, a staff
scientist at Lawrence Smith labs center
for applied scientific computing where
he develops efficient foundation models
for computational science. His research
focused on creating surrogates and
reduce order models to accelerate time
critical simulations in areas such as
immerse problems, design optimization
and uncertainty qualification.
He has pioneered advanced ROM techniques
including machine learning based
nonlinear manifolds, space-time ROMs,
component wise ROM automization and
latent space dynamics identification and
currently lead the librom team in
datadriven game modeling. His
contributions extend to open source
projects such as librom, pilrom,
lagosm, lassi and many more. Yu earned
his bachelor from Cornell and his PhD
from Stanford and he was a postto at
Sandia less and Stanford University
before joining Lawrence lith mole lab in
2017.
Today he will talk about defining
foundation models for computational
science toward clarity and rigor. Please
enjoy the wonderful talk. Now without
further ado let let me hand it over to
you. Well, thank you Uni
>> for nice introduction and hosting me uh
in DDPS seminar. I love DDPS seminar
series.
>> My pleasure.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Well, um yes,
thank you. Thank you for uh attending my
talk everyone. Uh today I'm going to
talk about uh defining foundation models
for computational science and we are
actually calling for more clarity and
vigor. Um, of course, uh, this work, uh,
was not possible without these awesome
co-authors. So, I definitely need to
recognize them. All right. Uh, I'm sure
uh, everyone here heard about foundation
models these days. It is definitely a
buzz word. Uh, because of that, perhaps
the the term foundation model is the
most controversial phrase in
computational science right now. So many
papers and preprints are uploaded these
days claiming that their models are
foundational. Um
are they really foundational? By the
way, um here are some typical types
which people claim that they their
models are foundational models. Um they
take scientific data of course and train
their models. Um popular models are
transformers uh graph neural network FNO
for neural operator and debon nets and
there are many others once they are
trained um almost like the off the
shelves they can predict new solutions
which is great and they can predict them
pretty fast which is also great.
However, once some problem setups
change, for example, changing geometric
domain or boundary condition, initial
condition, these models typically need
to be uh retrained. Uh some people argue
that they can do uh some fine-tuning
through the transfer learning, but even
the transfer learning can take hours and
hours if not days. Um it is the case
especially when a single training point
size is huge. Uh for example imagine
that you are using 5D toulence
simulation um uh data on tokome device.
Uh one single data point for this
particular problem is at least gigabytes
if not terabytes. it is pretty much
impossible to finish you know transfer
learning really really fast or real time
due to this humongous data size. Um so
generalizations to different task is
pretty much impossible. So these models
lacks generalizability and you know uh
it feels almost awkward to call them
foundation models. Well, then why do
people so badly want to label their work
a foundation model? And do we even have
a shared definition of what a foundation
model is in computational science? These
questions are what I want to talk about
today. At the end of the day and
throughout the talk, I hope to spark a
some fruitful discussions and questions
>> [snorts]
>> um that we can talk about. All right. Uh
let's deal with uh the first questions.
Why do we so badly want to label our
model as foundational? I guess it's
obvious. It is because the impact of
current foundation models is huge such
as GPT5 uh in CHP right now and birth
and clip for language and vision models.
Um you know it is basically changing the
way we live right now. Um Stanford
scholars wrote a uh preprint the title
uh of own the opportunities and risks of
foundation models. There they define the
foundation models as any model that is
trained on broad data generally using
selfs supervision at scale that can be
adapted for example fine-tuning to a
wide range of downstream tasks. For
example, um the broad data include text,
images, speech, uh structures, data, 3D
signals and many others. You collect
these big data to pre-train a model.
Then the pre-trained model is adapted to
wide range of tasks such as question
answering, sentiment analysis,
information extraction, etc., etc.
Well, people are impressed by these
models because they show immersion
behavior that is they can do the tasks
that were not explicitly trained to do.
Well, um Tom Brown currently in
anthropic and his co-authors describe
this emerging behavior in their paper uh
language models of view shot learners as
following. I'm I'm paraphrasing.
uh the unprecedented scale of GPT3 using
175 billion parameters has shown that
large language models can generalize to
a wide variety of task without task
specific training. They adapt at
inference time through natural language
prompts or a handful of demonstration
through few shot learning achieving
reasonable performance on many tasks
they were never explicitly trained to
do. I guess this emerging behavior can
be described as generalization to
diverse unseen downstream uh tasks.
Because of this fascinating emerging
behavior or foundation models in AI
field, it makes sense that people want
to label their models as foundation
model. However, unfortunately, we do not
have a single shared definition of
foundation models in computational
science. But one thing is clear um when
we define foundation models for
computational science we must explicitly
include this generalization capability
otherwise it should not be called
foundational.
Let's look at the computational science
science our own uh community. Uh we do
have the concept of foundational methods
in computational science right I mean
for example finite element methods um
finite volume methods which is popular
for fully simulations finite difference
method or spectral method and many
others. Uh these methods are called
foundational because they have several
features to be called foundational I
guess. Uh for example universality or
problem independent structure in
foundation mode methods um use general
strategy that apply across many areas.
For example in finite owner method we
always build the weak form and
discretize the domain. this fundamental
framework stays the same. uh while a
user only needs to change the inputs
like the material properties or boundary
conditions
and thanks to the great mathematicians
uh such as Hilbert Current and John
Vanimman uh these methods are supported
by a mature mathematical theory concepts
like convergence stability and error
analysis are well defined and studied
right and third software reusability
once implemented methods like uh finite
element method or finite volume method
can be reused across many different
problems by simply changing inputs such
as geometry or mesh. The solver code
doesn't need to rewriting. This is this
is great for general purpose framework
like and also extended to the high
performance computing and uh tackle
truly large scale problems. This is this
is very awesome.
Okay. So when you define foundation
models in AI sense and in computational
science sense, ideally we would like to
reflect those characteristics from both
fields and you know embedded that in our
definitions. That is exactly what we did
in our recent preprints. And here is our
version of definition. Um let's see you
are going to agree with it or not. Here
we go. A foundation model in
computational science is a datadriven
model trained on a broad distribution of
scientific application types or physical
systems which exhibits wide
generalization capability across
scientific problems, computational
domains, tasks and physical conditions
without requiring retraining from
scratch or structural modification and
serve as a reusable basis. As you can
see, we have uh listed five key features
in the definition. The first one is
datadriven. Of course, it's got to be
data driven otherwise it's not
foundation model in AI sense, right? And
those data has to be broad enough. I
mean you could use uh you you should be
able to use the data uh from the
solution of the Navia stocks uh
simulations, Maxwell equations, wave
transport, poison burgers and elast
elasticities and and and and so on and
on and on and [clears throat] once you
train uh your model um you know using
those broad data sets generalization
capability should show up. Um I mean
this generalization capability is a
feature of both AI and computational
science, right? I mean your model should
be able to tackle um you know problems
with diverse boundary conditions and for
different parameters and not only for
the uh the prediction of the for
uh calculations but also inverse
calculation right not just for the uh
single physics but also for multifysics
and for different equations right I mean
you use uh different uh diverse data so
it should be able to tackle different
types of the equations and also as you
change the geometry of the domain uh it
should be also still be able to solve
the uh the underlying problem and not
only the fold simulations that uh
deterministic problem uh but also
quantify some uncertainty and of course
you should be able to scale up uh to
truly large scale problem uh even though
your model might have been trained with
a small scale problems. Um
and um all of this capability should be
done uh with minimal uh fine-tuning like
almost like the no training from the
scratch. That was the feature of the
current foundation models like uh chipt
has for example and reusability should
be uh once it is trained the pre-trained
model should be reusable for many
different tasks and that's a feature of
both AI and computational science. Okay.
In addition to these five features in
the definition, we listed four
additional desirable characteristics
mainly because we would like to add
features from our traditional
computational science. Um first one
would be scientific consistency. Uh the
model should respect physical laws and
principles like conservation, symmetry
or invariance. I mean this in this
consistency builds interpretability and
credibility and um and many many good
things. I mean without you know this
physical law satisfaction and yeah it's
we shouldn't call uh the foundation
model um you know we shouldn't call our
model foundation models our opinion.
Okay. Then next the mathematical rigor
why where possible the model should be
supported by rigorous ma mathematical
analysis like stability convergence or
wellposeness and analysis just like the
foundational methods um in you know the
finite element method or finite volume
method right and the third robust
extrapolation um well reemphasizing the
broad generalizability in another words
I mean it should make reliable
predictions beyond its training region
um across new domains, boundary
conditions or longtime uh dynamics. Um
fourth uh is really um not coming from
the computational side but coming from
AI side data scalability because it
deals with the data. Ideally um as you
know increase the quality uh data and
use that in your training of your model
hopefully the performance of the model
should improve. Um
okay so we have just presented our own
definition and desirable
characteristics. Now you may ask and
often we get this questions from people
uh after those people read our uh
preprint. The the most frequent question
is is this foundation model even
realizable? Can you actually build a
model that satisfies all these criteria?
Right? I mean the definitions and traits
sound awesome following traits from
foundation models both in AI and
computational science. I mean it it
sounds like it's it's got to be that
right and but if you are actually
familiar with how computational science
works in general at first glance it
seems daunting and almost impossible to
build a model that satisfies all these
criteria. Why? It is simply because
computational science is not like
building a language model or visual
models. They are two different things.
Okay, let's see what are uh the
difference and you know you know that
causes some challenges to us to build a
truly foundation models in computational
science. Okay, first one is massive data
point size. Unlike tokens or image
patches in natural language processing
or vision, a single scientific data
point can be millions or even trillions
of values uh just like the uh the 5D
uh turbulent simulations um in tokcom
device which I have shared right with
you guys. And this overwhelms memory,
limits batch size and and slows training
and risks overfeitting right and the
second challenge would be the expensive
fine-tuning. I mean because of the data
is so humongous and um you know because
you have to deal with a different PD
types or different geometry or different
mesh resolution your downstream task um
it will be very inefficient and third
challenge data and heterogeneity
um scientific problems vary across
quantities dimensions depending on
dynamics and the governing physics some
data are scalers some are vectors even
answers. Well, designing one
architecture to cover all these diverse
um type of data pretty pretty difficult
and crucial the lack of standard uh
standard standardized data sets unlike
NLP and vision you know they have a
standardized data sets and community can
share them through the you know common
those data sets and they can compete and
improve their uh model but in compet
computational science we don't have a
large public data sets across uh physics
domains well there are some attempts to
you know address that issues uh the
example is the well the github
repository which is available publicly
right now and they collected many many
different scientific data at one places
and I see that uh the computational um
science community already using those
data and try to improve their uh models
and compare that with other people's
models and you know do the fair
comparison. So that kind of efforts we
need to keep uh pushing uh to improve.
Okay. Mesh and geometry dependency. Um
as you all know like simulation data
depends heavily on mesh and geometry and
the physics informed constraints as we
have um you know um uh alluded uh the
scientific system must obey the
conservation laws but a lot of blackbox
approach um it does not um it their uh
[snorts] simulation just uh in eyeball
norm looks good but that's not enough
for the scientific applications. Some
some are related issue would be the
trust and interpretability.
High stakes science demands
interpretable and verifiable models. Of
course um you know again pure blackbox
approaches are uh simply no good for
that. And uh the multiscale and the
longtime behavior many systems can spend
multiple scales in space and time.
Capturing longterm dynamics in one model
is extremely challenge. uh with all
these challenges it um it is very much
just justifiable uh for people to feel
that this definition we have introduced
and bring up to you guys uh is almost
impossible right so uh we had to provide
at least one framework uh which can
potentially realize a foundation model
that satisfy all these characteristics
that is why we have introduced
datadriven finite element methods DD FM
framework in our reprint
as the name indicates DDM datadriven
final method. It was inspired by
traditional finite element method FEM
which is one of the foundational uh
method in computational science as I
already said. So let's go over how the
traditional FEM works. Um what do you
do? You pick an elements. Um let's say
you have picked a tetrahedral element
that will serve as a local
representations whatever the global
domain uh solutions you you are going to
uh solve for. The second you assign a
usually typically polomial basis to
represent the solutions within that
local representations.
Um and then you collect all those many
many elements and glue them together
assemble a global uh discretized
computational domain and you'll solve
underlying partial differential
equations representing your uh the
physics problem you wanted to solve. And
once you solved it, it'll give you uh
the values of the unknown coefficient in
front of the polomial basis. And with
that values you can reconstruct uh the
solutions any time and any space and
very powerful very powerful tool indeed
it's a foundational methods in
computational science everyone agrees
with that uh because it has a
universality characteristics. It can
solve virtually any complex physical
problems with high precision and it's
definitely uh supported by mathematical
rigor and once the fan code is
implemented and it is widely widely
reusable to many different tasks right I
mean we do that like as Lawrence limo
national lab also relying heavily on
this fam to solve very important physics
and engineering problems like how the
that fusions and poke collapse and 3D
shape charts and uh many others are uh
we are relying on uh this FVM um to
tackle and you know improve and come up
with a scientific discovery. Uh however
there is a problem uh as you can already
see from this slide individual
simulation is taking really really long
like some of them takes weeks and days
and um you know many hours even using
the hyperformance computing um you know
we have at Lawrence Leong National Lab
and if you think about the reasons why
it's so uh it's clear that uh the uh you
know uh the the polomial basis we are
using is generic representation. It does
not know anything about the problem or
what you are going to solve etc etc. So
in order to improve the accuracy you
have to use a finer mesh or if you want
to uh keep the uh element size
relatively large then you need to use
the higher order polomial and inevitably
unfortunately uh that leads to a large
scale system of equations you have to
solve every iterations every time steps
and etc etc. So and you have to come up
with the preconditioners and so on and
so on. So it takes long time. So in
order to address that and also in an
effort to build a foundation model which
satisfies all those definitions I have
laid out uh in previous uh slides we
came up with the datadriven final method
and basically it's following the
traditional final method procedure
except the uh the polomial basis. We use
datadriven basis. So since it is
datadriven it's you know knows uh about
the problem you're going to solve
through data. So it's not generic form
uh as polomial basis and um hopefully it
knows about the problem. The quality of
the datadriven basis is going to be
better than polomial basis. And once you
have replaced the polomial basis with
the datadriven basis the rest of the
procedure is the same as the pretty much
same as uh the traditional final method.
you know collect them together form a
global domains uh extrapolation in space
right and and then you solve the uh
governing equations so it is indeed
using both data and physics um it's a
fused fusion method u of using both uh
data and physics okay a lot of benefit
comes out of it um simply um because of
the fact that we are building a data
view basis in a local region local
element uh as a representations.
The immediate things you can see is that
uh you do not have to generate the data
in the global domain on the complex
geometry. You only need to generate the
data on this unit cell or component or
subdomain or small element uh size uh
which it will be very efficient and you
can actually generate big data because
you you know those you know just
generating those data in the small
domain is you know people can easily do
that. Uh so obviously uh this tackles
the one of the challenges we have
mentioned like you know each uh single
data point size being large for
computational science right uh by
breaking this global domain into small
pieces like the element um you know the
data generations you have to do does not
have to be uh big uh it can be small
just like the large language models and
the visual models, they deal with the
patches and uh very small stuff and DDFM
allows you to deal with a small stuff
and therefore the training a datadriven
basis coming up with a um datadriven
basis is is very naturally efficient.
Okay. Okay. As I said the quality of the
datadriven basis um uh is probably
better than the polomial basis. So uh it
can um use a larger scale elements and
then um um that uh leads us to solve a
much larger scale problems right and uh
because you can use a larger element
size you can take a larger uh the time
steps and that leads you to uh solve a
longer time uh simulations that's good.
Okay, let's go more in depth in uh DDM
training assembly and prediction
procedure. In training, as I said, you
can finally generate big data because
the data generation is done in a small
local domain. You can include diverse
geometries, mesh types, boundary
conditions, parameters, etc., etc. And
also you can u solve many different
PTEs. This PD type one could be n
stocks. PD2 could be maxwell equation.
PDN would be uh you know transport
equation and so on and on and so on then
uh use this data to build a datadriven
basis and several ways of building this
datadriven basis are possible so that's
why we are calling this DDFM as a
framework not a specific method um and
I'm I'm going to um you know elaborate
on what kind of the ways of the building
the datadriven basis are possible in
next slide but once Once you build those
datadriven basis, uh we do global
assembly, right? Just to follow the
traditional final method uh procedure,
you form a global domain for uh any
arbitrary geometric shape by collecting
and gluing many uh the datadriven
elements together. You could potentially
deform the original element shape uh to
fit into a global domain by mapping from
reference to computational domain just
like the traditional binary method does.
And um there are different uh types of
assembly uh uh approach is possible just
like the fine animal method uh as well
the conforming or the non-conforming
assemblies are possible. So the examples
of the non-con non-conforming would be
you know following the discontinuous
gakin approach and once the global
domain is formed you can also um you can
solve the underlying governing equations
numerically right using these datadriven
elements instead of polomial basis.
Again because you are solving a physics
problem the solution you get will be
consistent with any underlying physics
laws you have used to solve you know
come up with a governing equations right
so it's a scientifically consistent
okay let's go into some more details as
I promised um what are uh several ways
to build a those datadriven basis the
first one would be compression based
approach where you use some compression
techniques tech such as singular value
de composition or tensor de composition
uh that are linear compression based or
thanks to the neural net and you can use
autoenccoder which is probably the most
popular uh way of compressing these days
in nonlinear fashions and you could use
those techniques to come up with a
compact social representations for each
element right and then uh the sparse and
symbolic uh regression based Uh this is
very interesting one as well and we are
actually exploring this route right now.
Uh where you use um data to come up with
a some sort of functional
representations or even you know some
sort of governing equation like that uh
partial differential equations or
ordinary differential equations in that
elements and then use that as a kind of
governing equations and you assemble
them together. So that's perfect uh for
when you do not have the governing
equations available. You only have the
data for the small scale. Then you can
still use those small scale data as a
patch and come up with a some identified
human identify or the algorithm that
identify the governing equations and you
can use that governing equations to
assemble them. Pretty cool idea. Okay.
The third one is implicit neural
representation or neural operator type
where you build input output mapping in
a mesh free fashions. These are um by no
means very popular these days. ANO and
deepones and many other neuro operators
are uh um are are those types of method
and uh um you could come up with a
hybrid mixed u basis as well. Well, I
mean you could um combine you know any
of these two uh or you could even
combine with a traditional polomial
basis with this data view basis and com
you know merge the the benefits of two
and then even strengthen the the
representations and that concept is very
similar to the generalized final method
or enriched fin method right where the
generic polomial basis is augmented to
additional basis to improve the
accuracy. Okay. um
this DDM
um which which I have just described
does have surprising similarity in
procedure to natural language models. So
you probably uh got hinted uh already
from you know some of the um you know
the the remarks I have made uh in
previous slides. And if you think about
it what does large language models do?
They take many hex data from internet or
books or various sources and breaks down
into small pieces and they call it a
token. If you think about it this is a
updown procedure. And then what does uh
LLM do? It assembles those small pieces
together to form a sentence and
paragraph or even a whole chapter of a
book. Um they do that using attention
and reasoning mechanism. This is a
bottom up uh procedure, right? But if
you think about it the DDM or even
traditional final methods once you have
a geometric domain on which you would
like to solve a physics problem you
break it down into small pieces and each
piece uh being called either subdomain
or elements we have been um and this is
topdown procedure right and then the
DDPM builds a data view basis for each
element and local representation
assemble them to form a global domain
again and predict the uh physics
solutions and as you can see this is
bottom up procedure. So do you see the
similarity between large language models
and DDM framework? Um and so maybe I can
end the talk today and here just
claiming that oh DDM is foundation
models uh um maybe not um maybe I need
to uh demonstrate more.
We do have some preliminary results uh
of the DDM. It is preliminary. So we do
not claim that we have completed the
development of the DDFM framework and
now you know we are claiming oh this is
true foundation models. No no no we are
not doing that but um uh we are not yet
there. Uh but we are going toward there
um okay so this evidence of the
preliminary results hopefully will show
you why we are claiming that. Okay, the
first uh example uh is going to be
lattice type structure problem. Uh this
will demonstrate the extrapolation in
space and also extensions to not only
the fold simulation but also the inverse
problem once you know the datadriven
element uh is trained. Okay. So lettuce
type structure
um you know I'm talking about like some
structure which can be formed by
repeatedly using this you know this uh
components like let's say str elements
and joint elements. So because those two
components are repeated uh in the
lettuce structure we can use those two
elements as a datadriven element right
and you form and generate a lot of data
on those components and we use the
compression technique to come up with a
datadriven basis and once that
datadriven basis is constructed and you
assemble them together to form this type
of lettuce structure I mean there are
many other lettuce structure
um which you can form with these two
components. Uh right but just to for the
demonstration this is one let structure
you can form. Of course you would like
to apply some pressure force or the
boundary conditions um to do some
displacement analysis or stress
analysis. And if you actually solve this
same system using monolithic traditional
finite anom method you need to solve for
2.7 million degrees of freedom. However,
because uh the compact solution
representation through the datadriven
basis for each element uh is a compact
representations uh if you solve this
problem with the DDM, you only need to
solve for 3,872
uh degrees of freedom. And once you
solve it, um it means the DDM is going
to give you like thousands of speedups
and less than 1% relative error. That's
that's um you know uh that's awesome.
But because it's very fast, we were able
to not only solve a forward displacement
analysis or stress analysis, we were
actually was about to solve a was was
able to solve a inverse problem as well.
uh like design optimization problem like
you know asking you know questions of
okay minimize the uh the weight of this
overall let structure but still you know
to hold this pressure force and the
boundary condition can you do that and
the design optimization inverse problem
lets you do that this video shows you
the progress of those uh the shape of
that let structure removing those parts
which is not necessary with a blue color
and um you know still gets a you know
gets you that optimal solutions with
thousands of speed up um uh accuracy. So
this um example demonstrate extraolation
in space like the generalizations
capability and also extensions to not
only the the fold simulations but also
the uh you know the inverse inverse
problems. How about you know
generalization to a much bigger domains
or much you know different geometric. Um
you know as you can see uh you could
come up with a different type of lettuce
structure by introducing m much many
more components and you can just reuse
the pre-trained datadriven basis. You
don't have to retrain them just you know
just off the shelves just grab it and
then use that for different geometry
problem and you can actually solve it uh
um still get the thousand speed up and
relative error less than 1% um you know
performance and you can also solve a you
know uh the inverse problem design
design optimization problem and come up
with a optimal design etc etc. Okay. Um
you might ask okay this problem is
simple is a linear you know time
independent problem. How about the
nonlinear problem? Yes we have
demonstrated the DD fan framework in uh
nonlinear problems. Uh here is porous
media nebia stocks uh uh problems and um
because there are different obstacle
shapes in the por media simulations we
come up with a five different elements
datadriven elements with a different
obstacle shape and you build a
datadriven basis for each one of them.
Um as you can see you know we do not
have to solve this gigantic global
domain systems to come up with a data.
We can just use the small domain and
then generate a lot of data on that each
element and um again use the compression
techniques to come up with a datadriven
basis. You assemble them together and
then um you know you form a global
domain and you solve a you know apply
the boundary conditions and you solve
this problem. We were able to get 25
times speed up compared to the
traditional finite element method and
less than 1% relative error. Okay. How
about time dependent problem right? Um
yes we were able to do so. Um this time
2D spatially distributed disturbance
burgers flow here we don't have any we
are not dealing with a porse media uh
simulation. So um only one single
elements uh was um enable us to come up
with a you know you know this this
datadriven basis for for this particular
problems. Of course we uh train the data
as basis using the small domain and then
once that is trained we can uh collect
many many of those and uh build a um you
know this much bigger uh problems and
again we got like thousands of speed up
and less than 1% relative error. Um how
about like generalization to different
source functions? I mean so in order to
demonstrate that we use the uh typical
senosidal source functions to generate
the datadriven basis uh the trained
datadriven basis and then of course if
you use the similar type of source
functions it it does work. Uh but um
even for the um different source
functions appending the exponential
functions on there and then make it the
the global domains uh the solution
manifold to be somewhat more spiral and
still was able to uh get uh the you know
accurate solutions. I think the relative
error was 0.7% or something like that.
Um so it works for different source
function and uh ultimate demonstrations
um for different partial differential
equations and um you know here just to
demonstrate that we collect uh the datas
from two different types of the PTE like
the quazone which is uh parabolic and
the burgers uh which is hyperbolic and
combine them and uh build a single
datadriven basis and then use that to
solve either both pos equations or
burgers equations um we were able to do
so with very high accuracy and also um
you know extrapolation in spa space uh
which we have been um you know
demonstrated so far is also possible
just using one single datadriven basis.
So hopefully this demonstrations um you
know
uh you know make you you know agree with
that DDM can be a foundation model in
computational science. I mean at least
it tours in in the right directions uh
because it allows a local training small
and and the uh global assembly and we
demonstrated the cross domain
generalizations right uh the parabolic
and the hyperbolic um one single data
driven basis were able to tackle that
and once that data basis is uh trained
you you can reuse that to solve many
different task uh and problems guys and
was was able to demonstrate the
space-time extrapolations and also
because you know the it it solves a um
the physics problem at the end you know
the solution is scientifically
consistent and you could see that from
the accuracy like less than 1% relative
error. um it's you know kind of showing
that it's a scientific consistency
consistency excuse me and just like the
finite uh traditional finite element
method um you know it's it can be easily
supported by the mathematical vigor
right uh those convergence analysis uh
welloseness analysis and stability
analysis since the DDFM is following the
very similar framework as the
traditional final method we could borrow
those uh the theory and then use that uh
for our benefits. Of course there are
difference. So we should be able to do
um come up with a new and modified
analysis but we don't the point is um we
don't have to start from the scratch.
Okay look for DDFM to be a foundation
model. Uh a lot of work needs to be
done. So uh we are calling out for the
collaborations. Uh we have a small
group. So uh we cannot do all these
developments um by ourselves. Um so more
collaboration is going uh is is welcome.
uh some some of the things there are
many works we need to do is some of the
works is you know enabling the
scalability of course if you even though
the each data uh datadriven element is
bigger than traditional finite element
um as you uh introduce many many
elements like that to solve a truly
large scale problems the system of
equations at the end of the day in DDFM
you have to solve is large scale too so
most likely you need to come up with a
preconditioner but the structure of the
system is different enough from
traditional final method. um you know
the the structure is a block very block
dense uh structure you are going to see
in in the system new type of
preconditioner is needed and as I
mentioned um you know some mathematical
uh theory needs to be u you know needs
to be explored and also like adaptive
refinement uh adaptive mesh refinement
strategy that sort of uh strategy can be
also applied to to the DDFM as well by
come up with some error indicator uh to
find out where in in the domain is going
bad and we can actually uh do different
types of refinement and you know h
refinement or p refinement here in the
DDM sense would be you know increase the
dimension of the datadriven basis right
and also we have to explore the uh
different types of assembly and we are
looking at different types of the
non-conforming uh assembly right now. um
and um software re usability I mean all
those implementation has to be user
friendly um it's got to be accessible to
the domain scientists um and they should
be able to offtheshelf just change the
input files and should be able to tackle
many different types of the problems
right okay um so with that I guess I can
finish my talk here is the preprints um
um you know a lot more details are
written in this preprints and So I
welcome everyone here to go into that uh
you know to find out those details and
as a team uh the libron team uh we try
to make our the resources available to
uh everyone. Uh so we do have some
YouTube tutorials talking about you know
datadriven video models and surrogate
models and some uh t you know typical uh
techniques widely used in in our
community so that you can get familiar
with it. It's the individual YouTube
tutorial is not that long like 5 minutes
10 minutes. So uh so you don't have to
spend a lot of times watching it. Uh but
I think it's very useful and uh we have
a libram.net that web page which
collects all those uh informations about
the resources including the GitHub
repository of many many source codes we
have developed so far and uh the Libram
some of the codes we have developed C++
so always compiling C++ code is a the
hassles uh but if you have happens to
have a AWS cloud computing access then
there is a Libra version which is
already compiled for you so you don't
have to worry about the compiling and
generate many many results uh which is
um you know demonstrated in this libr.
web page. Okay, with that um let me
acknowledge some funding um and um you
know
yeah wrap up the talk. Thank you for
listening.
>> Okay. Um thanks for the wonderful talk
and the summary of the team's reio. Uh
since I'm part of this work, I will be
stepping back from asking questions to
ensure we can focus on the insights from
the audience. So if you have any
questions, um I see a few already I
guess um comments and thoughts. Please
feel free to unmute yourself. Um
>> you may want to call out the name. Yeah,
probably let's start with a question in
the chat chat room. Uh, a building
asked, do you see a single foundational
model being able to generalize across
different physical problems such as gas
against liquid flows?
Uh well that yeah that's good questions
and um I mean DD fan I mean which we are
advertising right now. Um
uh we are trying to uh build a single
foundation model which can be
generalized to uh across many different
physics problem in PTE sense like the
partial differential equation sense. I
mean even there you know so many
different physics problem is represented
by different partial differential
equations right uh as long as you know a
single foundation model can handle those
different types of PTE I mean I truly
believe that you know um that is true
foundation models so and that's what DDM
is aiming uh aiming to accomplish I mean
there are many other foundation models
um in different domains right for
example material science um uh where
they look at the molecular dynamics and
uh try to come up with a you know
appropriate potentials calculation of of
the potentials with single model they
use GNN and they use transformers etc
and I do believe that they can be called
uh as a foundation model within that
domain uh that limited domain uh so as
long as you you you um uh clearly state
that okay what do what do you mean by
foundation model um you know in which
domain which specific uh areas I think
yes I mean you can you can you can come
up with a single uh foundation models
which which can which can u deal with a
many different problems yeah
>> okay uh I saw a few more questions in
sharing but let's give a chance to for
the audience who raised hands Uh I'm
going to call names that appear in
order. So with Jeremy,
>> hi uh Yang Su this is a nice talk. Um I
guess
>> um you know the you know that uh you
know historically this is is you know
related to the structural you know to
what we used to call substructuring.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But um I guess the one
thing that is kind of which is the
problem there and the problem not
necessarily the problem but the
challenge here
>> comes down to the fact that if you make
a macro element
>> right
>> um
>> uh it's it's going to be valid basically
for a certain set of
um
inputs. uh you you know the you had an
example where you were training it based
upon homogeneous flow you know at the
inlets and outlets right
>> yeah right um and of course you know you
can train it for some
some subset of more general outflow
conditions right inflow conditions
>> but eventually if you make it if if you
want to make that um macroelement, you
know, as general as the finite element
method that was underneath it, you'd
have to have,
>> you know, a vast array of those.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Right. So the challenge which has
always been the kind of the challenge
for these um for these substructuring
methods uh really does come down to you
know the first question is error
estimation. Yeah.
>> Right. And then the second question is
okay after you've done you say oh you we
got some error now how do we go back and
>> you might say add basis functions
retrain etc.
>> But you know those are the challenges. I
mean it's again it's it's you know it's
interesting and and nice stuff. I just
you know if you make that if you make
that macro element as general as the
finite element method that you came back
from you end up with something that's
basically the same order of complexity.
So that's where the you know the
challenge is is to you know figure out
how to start basically with a simplest
lowest order thing you might say and
then have some adaptivity to try to pull
in what's what's necessary
you might say. Yeah, I mean yeah those
challenges you have just listed
I totally agree with you that's a
challenge and but at the same time I
think that's an opportunity
>> and uh thanks to this you know great
improvements and you know a lot of
things going on in AI uh world you know
thanks to the neural net representations
and those um you know the expressibility
ility of each uh substructure um
solution representation can be greatly
improved um by you know borrowing those
uh architectures.
Um and as you mentioned that you know
that error analysis uh which can we once
it is established then as you said we
can go back and then use that uh
analysis to guide us you know how to
improve the um you know data sampling
for examples and improve the you know
the expressibility of the neuron net um
I probably wouldn't have came Oh, we
couldn't probably come up with this you
know so-called the DDFM framework and
claiming that oh these could be
foundation models if there were no like
resources available like the neuronet
and transformers and uh etc which is has
been developed in AI AI side. uh thanks
to those uh the developments now we can
borrow those things and then try to
address the challenges you have uh
mentioned. So I I think there's there's
a great possibility and we have a great
hope um to believe that those challenge
can be eventually addressed in in very
you know [clears throat]
constructive and structured manner. Um,
we'll see. We'll see.
>> Right. Thank you so much. I got to run
to another meeting. So, thank you so
much.
>> Thank you.
>> Um,
she uh do you want to ask a question if
you want to please unmute yourself?
>> Yeah, sure. Uh, thank you for the great
presentation. I really enjoy it and
I really enjoyed uh your presentation.
uh and yeah uh as a domain scientist
myself I I think the most part that I
really like is that you know there's no
need to retrain this model when I want
to use it because you know in many case
you know there are many great machine
learning models that I want to use
>> but uh then I have to start with the
training uh which you know often they
could act as like deal breaker to me
>> exactly
>> at least to me
>> so uh one question I have is
[clears throat]
not a computer scientist. Is this might
be a live question but uh I was
wondering uh if it is possible to let
this DDFM
uh to use or to focus on subset of PDEs.
>> [snorts]
>> uh
>> as you indicated earlier you know
different problems have focus on
different pds
>> and I was thinking of some cases like
you know turbulence and climate as I'm
in the climate field uh both turbulence
scale and climate scale are both are
using nav toxication but
>> uh while turbulence is focusing on more
on like energy propagation from large
scale to small scale
>> but climate is less focusing on this
small case but more focusing on energy
conservation overall. So in that case
different subset of PDS are going to be
used or prior prioritized.
>> So I was wondering if uh that kind in
that kind of case this
user can like give a comment like oh
focus on this PD instead of
ignore or give less priority to this
opt.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Exactly. Um I mean as you can see from
our demonstrations like this individual
elements uh they differ by just by
looking at it the shape is different
right? I mean some of them does not have
holes some of them has circular hole
star shape. And I mean if you go to the
lettuce type structure um examples I
show the actual shape of each element is
it can be um what is it this polygon uh
name how many edges are there I'm really
bad at um the geometry I got to go back
to the middle school and then
anyway um so it can the shape and the
the the nature of that datadriven
element could differ by by many
different factors like and one of the
factors could be PTE and I do think that
we can we we the nice thing about the
DDFM is you can come up with a tailored
datadriven basis which can be more
specialized to specific PT as you just
mentioned. I mean if you just
[clears throat]
stay in one um the fluid reason I mean
even the CFD computational science I
mean the computational fluid dynamics
you have a subsonic flow transic flow
supersonic flow and all those different
types of flow you actually come up with
a different treatment of the finite
element method if you are using the
final method right I mean if you're
using finite volume method you you you
basically come up with a tailored the
treatment of those different um the
flows although the underlying the
framework is the same. So at DDM you
could view it as um the you know similar
[clears throat and snorts] um you know
the framework is the same and everything
is um sim the similar but you could come
up with a tailored data basis for the
subsonic transic and supersonic or the
climate science and the uh or the um you
know turbine uh the simulations etc. Yes
I mean I totally agree with you.
>> Thank you sir. Thank you.
[clears throat]
>> Okay. Um,
so, uh, I know we have overrun a little,
but there are few more interesting
questions in the chat room. So, I'll
read out one by one.
>> Yeah.
>> Nicholas asked, "Hi, a very interesting
and clear talk." Thank you. How much of
what you present is tied to the F method
as compared to say final volume method
or others?
>> Oh, yeah. Thank you for asking that.
actually
uh it's not like strongly tied. Uh the
reason we are calling that datadriven
final method is the the the framework is
kind of following this procedure is kind
kind of following the finite element
method. However, uh for example, this
um you know demonstration we have shown
you this individual data uh has been
generated by using finite difference
method and then all those assembly and
um you know system of you know resultant
system of equations we we had to solve
in DDM also follow the finite uh
difference uh discretization. So
>> yeah, it's it doesn't um thank you for
the questions. It the DDFM does not
strictly tie to the FEM. It's just a
naming. Um you could bring the f uh
finite volume method or you could even
bring the spectral method or element
wise or the finite difference method and
many other discretization method and
apply that in in the framework of the EG
plan.
>> I hope that answers Nicholas's question.
Um the next question is from Adam. Do
you think the frontier large language
models like CHBT are the appropriate
space to build computational science
foundation models?
Well, I mean they are as I um explained
the although DDM and the large language
models are similar um you know the top
down and bottom up analogy I made um but
you know in the challenge part it is
very different enough right um so
I mean we could borrow the concept of
the large language models and then bring
into uh to build a our own foundation
models in computational science But I
don't think is you know you know
directly just off the shelf you know
grab the large language models and then
use that in um um as a basis for the
computational science. So you you do
have to uh modify and um cause the
computational science is different from
large language models for many different
reasons uh which I have listed in in
here. So yes I I I think we we can
borrow the concept but the um yeah I
don't think we can use that as a
offtheshelf as a base.
>> Okay. Um the next question is from Alex.
For the topology optimization problem
was the optimization method gradient
based? Have you attempt to extend the
topology optimization to nonlinear or
temporal problems?
>> Oh yeah. Well I mean we want to go
there. Yes, definitely. Uh we did use
the gradient based optimi optimization
solver. Uh so um you know individual uh
the elements datadriven basis we had to
come up with a gradient of those um with
respect to appropriate u variables and
uh you know glue glue them together um
and following the adjoin uh the
formulations to come up with a gradient
for whatever the objective functions and
constraints we have imposed. So uh yes
and and um we would like to extend it to
the nonlinear uh temporal problems in
topology optimization that would be that
would be fantastic but I mean we do have
a limited number of people I mean Alex
if you're um in that field let's do that
together.
>> Yeah. Okay. Uh
Johans asked, "Hi, it's a great talk.
I'm curious if DDFM can be extended to
integral PDEs which are inherently
global problems." Uh yeah I means yeah
if that integral is has to be the global
um and and there's no really a way of
breaking down breaking down into the
subdomains
uh because of the nature of the
formulations
uh probably it's hard to do so but you
know I mean that's um integral PTE I do
believe that you know each self-domains
you can bring those techniques in uh
handle the integral PDEs and if we can
come up with a way of assembling them
together uh not breaking those in
inherently uh global nature uh because
at the end of the day what DDPM does is
actually solving the global problem
anyway I mean the the the things the DD
uh datadriven basis needs to represent
is just a local representations but it
it works together with other datadriven
elements um in that global domain. So um
probably there's a way of extending the
DDM to the integral PDS. I I do believe
that but I we have to look into the
details. Always the devil is in details.
So
okay uh the one last question I see in
the chat room is from Zenus. For ARM
foundation models, one of their key
capabilities enabling flexible
generalization is their ability to
utilize a provided problem context to
condition their responses such as the
context provided within user prompts.
>> So the definition of computational
science foundation models also
incorporate a similar similar capability
to flexibly leverage adapt to different
program contests.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um I mean that's what
we try to contain in our own definition
of foundation model in computational
science and uh as a you know potential
demonstration of that definitions uh
through DDM
uh you know I totally agree with you you
know that uh the context um I mean we
intentionally use existing governing
equations as a context right I mean when
they do the assembly um you know to come
up with a global representations of the
paragraph or the you know the chapters
in the book you know as as a cohesive um
um you know representations
>> in DDM in computational science uh the
one thing we can use is existing
governing equations which actually
describing your underlying physics and
you can use that to you know come up
with a global representation so so
there's a great analogy between large
language models and DDM there as well
Okay. Um I guess we have quite many
questions already. Let's thank you again
for the great talk and the audience who
raised excellent questions and foster
feral discussions here. Uh we might not
get to all of your questions and
comments today particularly the deeper
force this hot topic often inspires. So
please feel free to email and the team
offline with any specific questions or
ideas. Okay. Uh let's call this meeting.
Thank you.